sunburned tomato here how's it going
everyone that's right I go outside for
five minutes by Ginga and I'm back in
everybody where I belong you know
wherever I talk to people online that
maybe don't know who I am I'm always hit
with it yeah I did guys it's me it's me
guys it's 30pi why don't you believe me
when it turns out the reason why people
treat me with such indignity such
disrespect it's because there's a red
it's based on disputing these sort of
claims okay
I am PewDiePie I promise stop so let's
review some of the top ones on that
totally happened you and me together
it's not like I went to Walmart to buy a
tube of cookie dough and a box of tampon
and as a 17 year old boy was ringing up
my stuff he just looked at me and said
it's going to be okay reply and just
after that he said by the way I'm 17
years old I wanted you to know that so
you can describe me in your fake text
post on tumblr bazinga that's right how
could you possibly know that she was -
he was 17 hmm I feel like tumblers do
this especially I kind of get it now it
took me one post and I mean it's easy
we're just supposed to take everything
at face value no no not me I'm an
intellectual eyebrows read it
occasionally I was in the bank with my
five-year-old sister when we hear
everyone get down we all got down except
my sister who say stealing is wrong I
can already tell this is gonna be great
the robbers bolted out and everyone
stood and clapped the bank manager gave
us 1000 pounds for saving the day as
well laughing crying emoji laughing
crying emoji laughing crying emoji could
this be a whoosh you know this is
obviously fake on purpose right
you got faker Deckard I love these these
verified Twitter tweets everyone dies
one day everyone even bulls but not
books not words what
don't die my son three who is a lot
smarter than I am it must be so great to
have a fictional three-year-old you
don't have to even change the diapers
awesome it's like oh I have this
somewhat decent tweet what if I credit
it to my three-year-old then it would be
amazing this is actually our quit your
bull but you know you know what story is
true if you you started off with
literally they literally ban camera pans
from my old school because people can't
make an invisible jokes and one teacher
had a mental breakdown and decided to
quit because of them that's right a
teacher decided to quit school because
people just kept making camouflage jokes
I understand that's that's what drives a
teacher over the edge my English teacher
wrote part of a poem I wrote on the
board today which honestly surprised me
she had the student guess who wrote it
and most of the answers were the
President or Shakespeare when my teacher
revealed that it was I who wrote it
I received an applause and then the
President himself came out and
congratulate me and Shakespeare rose
from the dead and say well done to thee
I have never lied in my entire life this
would never happen to me you'll never
see PewDiePie on this board teacher I
want everyone to write down the people
that inspire you the most teacher walks
over it looks at my paper who are these
gentlemen with colored hair they're
youtubers they're not really
inspirational people dear they just sit
around at home and talk to camera all
day meet teacher you just stand around
and talk to kids that aren't even paying
attention to you all day continued
writing youtubers names
[Music]
here's another PewDiePie one I pull down
my pants and press them against the
monitor then my mom walked in and I was
like mom don't look at me Peter pie told
me to really what you should have said
is mom look at me that totally happened
while shopping at in Target I heard a
girl
say boys are so dumb to which I replied
say it louder to the girls in the back
to which she screamed boys are so dumb -
which other customers replied with a
slow clap best target experience yet
boys are so dumb can this video hit
5,000 likes boys are so dumb if she said
women are so dumb boy don't even make me
comment about the hypocrisy lib tardes
you wouldn't even care would you
pathetic oh my god I asked this girl in
my class for a piece of gum every day
for the whole semester today was our
last day and I asked her for a gum and
she gave me the whole pack as a parting
gift if it ain't the smoothness thing I
have ever seen so she wrote her number
on each piece of the gum number one how
will you know the order of them number
two that didn't happen you're a virgin
similar thing happened to me the other
night my cab driver had my life by $0.50
and Eminem on and asked me if I wanted
to change it to country I responded by
wrapping the rest of the song word for
word then the taxi clad even if that
happened
it's just cringy alright don't care if
it happened how about that how about
sided subreddit for you if I lose this
bet I'll eat my hat
physics teacher who proceeded to lose
the bet take his hat dissolve it in acid
neutralize it with a base making it
water pour the mixture into his coffee
and down it in one cup that most
certainly happened as one teacher does
of course oh not a problem for me to eat
his hat I'll just dissolve it in acid
and neutralize it with the face making
it
hmm why do people bother why do people
bother okay so like I'm sleepy as hell
lmao I thought I put on my work shoes
walked out of the house like damn my
feet cold as hell of course of course
who doesn't lace their shoe on the
outside and not notice it on both feet
of course of course that happens my high
school had such a large population of
emos that when my MCR broke up they
announced it via the PA and offered
extra counseling that day how about our
if it's true you're all a bunch of [ __ ]
boys how about that is that a good
subreddit I was at Dunkin Donuts and
asked for three donuts and a water cup
the entire staff thought I said three
donuts in a water cup here's a result
can't make this yes you can stop lying
I'm sick of your lies that didn't happen
did it say it say it you dumped those
doughnuts you put those doughnuts in
that water no one else stop it get some
help
my gender studies professor told me to
go to Subway and snap a picture of a
male worker making me a sandwich as
extra cred hashtag patriarchy it's funny
because gender studies degree only
legitimately qualifies you for a job at
Subway there's no shame in making the
sandwich tonight at the gym a man looks
like a thing Thor go ask me out when I
told him I was a lesbo he goes oh chill
you know my sister and I work out a lot
together she'll be here tomorrow same
time like did door just wingman me god
of lesbos we have found the picture of
Thor this is what he looked like this
did actually in fact happen what an
incredible story this is why I hate
stories and I hate telling them because
I don't believe myself even telling a
story and I most suddenly don't believe
other people yes hope you guys had a
great Thanksgiving me actually I don't
find it fun to celebrate genocide and
colonization so I spent this
Thanksgiving blogging and protesting but
thanks how was yours the class actually
I was a teacher it was incredible and
then she did a backflip I left a
six-figure job at NASA to have no
responsibilities working as a cook at
McDonald's not kidding happiest I've
ever be oh it's your name Kevin Spacey
and do you live in the American Beauty
universe is that what happened you did
steak stories from movies and apply them
to your own things is that it pathetic
not even McDonald's want you okay over
at McDonald's though we're hiring guys
check out new merch link in the
description I purchased a plane ticket
online and went to the effing Airport
and got on an effing plane and now I'm
in Sweden drunk me is an effing mental
case health this is actually true that
was me I was traveling home to see my
parents and I got confused
this actually totally happened I feel
like the reason why these posts appear
so frequently online is because
face-to-face you know I can tell when
people are lying I'm pretty good at it I
think most people can tell when
someone's lying we don't really want to
confront people face to face you won't
really necessarily it's easier to just
go wild what a cool story instead of
going I don't believe that happened
unless it's someone I know very closely
like if my neighbor is a small talking
with me telling me some story I'm not
just gonna call them out be like ya know
you're foolish and I think that's why so
often on Facebook people just post
whatever because they're so used to
getting away with these lies so it's an
interesting phenomena what do you guys
think let me know in the comments tell
me a story that I definitely happen to
you I'd be very interested to hear about
it thank you for watching this video
leave a like if you enjoyed check out
the March guys I really appreciate the
support so far has been amazing this has
been pity pie bye